pretty soon we're gonna be getting
married
but i thought you know
uh you kristen and landry we could all
go dress shopping together what
why i'm not coming there why are you
with me in the window i'm not supposed
to see your wife in their wedding
now why in the world does leandro need
to go wedding dress shopping with ari
just show up to the ceremony i mean
enough already binyum gets visibly upset
after ari tells him she wants her
ex-husband leandro to go wedding dress
shopping with her
maybe he's looking when she's changing
stress and my first thought is
if you want someone to respect what
makes you uncomfortable
so you didn't think to tell me that you
would be training with a girl shouldn't
you do the same i think carrying
me around for dress shopping may make
him feel insecure then why are you going
we're gonna talk about it plus
i just feel like muhammad would be an
amazing father eve reveals that she
wants to have a baby with muhammad
which shocked me
but then he goes and tells the cameras
she wouldn't make a good mother to their
child wait he said that i wouldn't be a
good mother or i would
and i got eve's first-hand reaction
you were raised too freely and he
doesn't want his child
to be right to be influenced that way oh
that's interesting see
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio
leandro is officially back
i married landra like when i was 19.
we weren't together for almost 10 years
and i can you said it best quote i
rolled my eyes when i heard about the
ex-husband
girl you and a lot of other people and
he's coming in strong at the top of the
episode ari tells leandro she doesn't
know if she would marry benny if it
wasn't for avi
and when they all meet up for lunch
there is a lot of passive aggressive
behavior going on between him and binium
we're just talking that about it
[Music]
it feels like benny and leandro are
secretly fighting over ari and she's
secretly trying to make the both of them
jealous
it's weird
so how was the the fight they start to
talk about binyam's mma match and ari
brings up what kathy ayo graham calls
the time benny kicked leandro's butt he
ended it the same way that i think he
ended you yeah oh god
he hit that man in the head
i don't know leandro said oh no wait
you're doing a little too much here
ari was right he ended both fights the
same way that must be binium's signature
move
you got me my surprise with that one
props to leandro for not holding on to
that
but just when you think things are going
in a more lighthearted direction ari
brings up benny training with the mma
fighter melissa
this girl at the gym who thinks she's a
girl yes
she's she's
she's not she's good we didn't work
conflicts yeah but he just neglected to
tell me that he was training with a girl
at the gym
it doesn't seem that you communicate
enough
i used to make that mistake i'm just
telling you so
i learned it through time with other
relationships too yeah but
already we're talking about it like uh
above like for this situation
i'm just telling you
as an advice after leandro gives his
unsolicited advice he also tells the
producers that binyam isn't paying
enough attention to ari when you don't
pay enough attention to your lower well
that is when
the relationship starts dying
now what happens next
i think it's for tv and entertainment
purposes only because it doesn't make
any sense
the ethiopian new year is coming up and
benny is all excited to celebrate in the
u.s
i won't take my family just
maybe to be a restaurant just eating
just he took them food
did you notice how binion said my family
when describing ari's family i won't
take my family yeah just keep that in
mind
after benny reveals his plans
ari invites leandro to the party which
just seems like a stretch
why
it's benny's day
i thought it'd be really cool for you to
come and celebrate it with us and
although he goes along with it
yeah
benny tries to give leandro a hint to
say no
so if you want just you can come if
you're
i think you are busy just
you know her family is my family
so
yes i i'd like to participate it's a
battle of the egos at this point versus
benjamin's family now it's leandro's
family
ah your family is my family and ari is
just in the middle
this is gonna be fun look at leandro's
face he knows it's messy and bingham is
probably thinking at least he knows you
get your ass b try me if you want to
fast forward to the ethiopian new year
happy new year
benny ari her mom and dad are all at an
ethiopian restaurant intentions rise
once leandro joins
for one it's clear as day how much ari's
parents love leandro it's especially
significant for us because leander is
celebrating with us leandro has been in
our family for more than 10 years so
the entire family has tight
relationships with him there's even this
moment where they ask binyam about the
ethiopian dishes and as he's describing
the food
they turn and start having a
conversation with leandro this one is
adorable it's a chicken this is a lentil
it's different than argentina oh
argentina we are very big
beef with food yeah is that and i like
argentinian
oh my
god hmm
you can say that again binium
i know that had to suck and oh yeah i
think benny tried to choke leandro again
just in another way
in ethiopian culture and they do gosha
which is like when they
uh feed each other and it's like a sign
of respect and affection you are my
brother in eutopia we didn't feed you
now we will feed you when an ethiopian
ethiopian
i can do i can do that
you're too skinny oh
that's good like
strong
i don't know what bini's intentions was
by feeding me that much food that was
weird but maybe bin is trying to
eliminate the threat
at all costs uh yeah
leandra be careful ari's sister joins
them and binyam starts to explain what
else he does to celebrate the new year
and his answer put him in the hot seat
we change a new thing we change the
paintings the house neo
like we need everything is new not just
happy new year like new changes for the
year
nothing just like you start telling the
truth all the time
oh
burn i like these changes so what are
the changes that are gonna happen in
this relationship
that's none of your damn business
leandro
boundaries
so what are the changes that are gonna
happen in this relationship
like are you like you know sometimes
she's she don't have patience like
something just
i don't want like open for her like like
too much but maybe you should been here
maybe you should just try to tell her
everything everything what about the
fishy yellow i mean like
you have to make a deal yeah no if he
tells you the truth you don't yell
let's take a look at cynthia celina's
comment
she pointed out the double standard
that's going on here she says quote just
like the time she stayed at her
ex-husband's house while pregnant and
asked her ex to bring her bras and
whatnot she didn't think she had to
mention that
to be honest all of what ari and benny
are going through
reminds me of times in my relationships
where i felt like i could do something
but the moment you did it it was a
problem
i know it's selfish and it's immature
and this is no excuse but i think for me
it was coming from a place of
i trust myself not to hurt you but
i don't trust you not to hurt me
and i'm not saying that's the case for
ari and benny but it's clear that they
are mirroring each other right now
they're both asking each other for the
same thing which is to respect what
makes me uncomfortable
for ari it's benny's lack of
communication that makes her
uncomfortable for benny it's already
involving leandro in everything that
makes him uncomfortable but i'm not
comfortable with it yet they're both
resisting making adjustments for each
other when you have to be what you're
asking for pretty soon we're going to be
getting married
but i thought you know
you kristen and landr we could all go
dress shopping together
what i guess ari didn't feel the need to
mention this to bingham either
why i'm not coming there why you want me
in the window i'm not supposed to see
your wife in their wedding dress
i don't want you choosing my wife's
dress it's not a good idea for me
i'm not happy for that
because i don't trust him maybe he's
looking when she's changing stress it's
not my culture
i don't think so even american culture
why don't you go with your mom's like
the suspension if you're going with a
girl
what do y'all think about ari wanting to
take leandro wedding dress shopping with
her
i know they have a unique relationship i
get it i respect it
but most women would only want their ex
to join them so they can rub it in their
face
i'm just hoping she doesn't put on the
dress and look at leandro and say hmm
this still could have been yours similar
to what she did with the baby
you could've had a baby like this but
you didn't you missed out
look i like ari but the wedding dress
situation it's so unnecessary and like i
said earlier
i hope it's only for entertainment
purposes
i think kind me around for dress
shopping may make him feel insecure
but i'm here to support ari i think
he'll feel more comfortable if i wasn't
part of the family
but he has to accept
i'm not going anywhere
i don't trust for a situation with
leandro
leandro before he have a good chance was
as
they broke up as an end i said that's
what i i feel like oh you came here
i wish please get out of my life that's
what i want like i hear you ben young
but i'm not gonna lie avi has me
distracted
i just want to know what he's looking at
whatever is on that phone has him in a
trance
so cute
oh this binium ahri and leandro
situation
it looks like we're going to see more of
it
next week leandro is there while ari and
benny potentially face some
life-changing news
honestly i'm not really feeling well
what are you feeling just like something
feeling what means i'm a little nauseous
when was the last time you got your
period oh my god
sorry
wow
oh is she pregnant
i can't wait to find out and speaking of
babies to my surprise eve wants to have
one with muhammad i always wanted
another baby i just feel like muhammad
would be an amazing father
he's just so great with theron so
i would really love to share that
experience with him and the reality is
is
i'm worried about
the time frame and my age
eve's 48 by the way
while walking on the treadmill they
start to talk about plans to have a
child together and muhammad is open to
it until he starts to talk about taking
the kid to the mosque and eve is like
hold up wait what if the child is more
interested in my form of spirituality
that's when muhammad shut things down
let me make something clear
my child
you can't get him confused about his
religion
how do you know it's gonna be a he
muhammad you can't get him confused
about his religion if the child will be
raising in the spirituality that eve
lives in
it's going to end up with the kid
drinking alcohol and dating and
doesn't know what he should do
eve
was raised
with
let's say too much freedom
and i don't think
that she's going to be a good behavior
for my child oh eve i think you're
dodging a bullet here
interestingly enough she had no clue
muhammad said those things about her
until i asked her about it during our
chat
wait he said that i wouldn't be a good
mother or i would you were you were
raised too freely and he doesn't want
his child
um to be right to be influenced that way
oh that's interesting see
that's good for me to know and if he
doesn't feel like confident or
comfortable with how he thinks i'd raise
a child and of course not but i i think
i'm a pretty good mother and theron is
the proof in the pudding i know that's
right
to hear more of my conversation with eve
where we talk about muhammad's hypocrisy
and where their relationship stands
check out entertainment tonight's
youtube channel and et online.com
let me be very straight with you all
right back to the episode muhammad ends
a conversation about having children
with eve by telling her if the child is
not muslim
he prefers not to have one
i don't think that's fair for you to say
i am definitely shocked
ultimately i want our child to be able
to pick
what they want to believe in at some
point
and i don't think that he has a
realistic
perspective on that
so i don't know whether i
am okay with this
compatibility compatibility
compatibility
that's all i'm going to say
next week muhammad threatens to pack his
bags and if i was eve
i would have told him to call tyrone
so unfortunately we're gonna have to
push the wedding back like a whole other
month are you kidding me
i want my green card
if she doesn't want to file this
paperwork why she
bring me here like i don't understand
maybe you don't want to get married
i can't start back in my bags
bye mohammed
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
[Music]
you